hillary the finale is finally here what
can fans expect yes oh my god i can't
believe the finale's here first of all
it went by so fast what can i tease i
i'm gonna dare people to not cry like
every time i've watched the finale which
has been maybe two or three times now
and i'm a part of the show i get really
emotional so the um the the season
like
leans on a cliff like on a cliffhanger
and it's kind of emotional even though
our show is a comedy and it's funny and
it is definitely giving people a break
from the heaviness of life right now um
it's still you know these characters are
still going through very real things for
their life and our writers are so damn
good and we have a very exciting guest
joining us that i think people want to
tune in to watch and see
um you know we've had some
peppering of like
nuggets from the original show all
throughout the season but this is a very
exciting one you mentioned the
cliffhangers obviously it's a good thing
we're renewed for season two how excited
are you to keep telling these stories
you know what honestly i've been doing
this for such a long time and i think
that
i tend to try not get too excited and
get my heart you know really like
latched on to something because this
business is so like fickle but also
wonderful it can be like such a great
ride um and i think from day one we all
knew we were kind of sitting on
something special once the cast came
together and we were getting you know
deeper into the season and watching the
characters develop like we're like oh we
think oh sorry oh
oh
oh my god we have something kind of
great and um
and so you know to have the opportunity
to keep telling the story and to have
hulu behind it and say okay great you
guys did 10 episodes but now we want 20.
like that's amazing and that really
gives a
big confidence boost to what we're doing
and you know we'll get to have a little
bit more breathing room throughout the
season and everybody will get their own
stories and adventures to go on so it's
like it's freaking amazing i'm so happy
to have a job in l.a too
i'm like oh my god i don't have to
travel as much this is great i have to
say i am so jealous that you and your
son went to the justin bieber concert i
know hard pivot there but did you get
all the cool mom points with that you
know what it
was i can't believe i'm at this age and
i've been a mom like he's turning 10
this month so i've been a mom for 10
years and i'm like
today i was sitting there thinking about
what i'm gonna write in his birthday
card because i i
i don't know what i would have been
doing these these 10 years like it's
been such an adventure and he
gave me this confidence and these
memories and and to like honestly go to
justin bieber with him and on a school
night it was like a little naughty
and we went and we ate it like bestia
before and had like delicious pasta i
know and we were there with his best
friend and my best friend and it was it
was so much fun and he was falling
asleep on my shoulder during the like
album songs and then when the hits would
come on he would like pop up and be like
yes and i'm like this is dreams i'm so
happy and baby mae's standing now like
where is the time going i don't know
it's so weird and i know i know i don't
know she's she
is really cool and to be honest with you
the third child you just don't have as
much time for and she's doing these
things all on her own like i think that
with luca and banks we used to be like
where's your head where's your this
where's your that oh can you do this and
like
she just kind of like goes on the hip
and then she gets brought along for
everything and so when she does cool
things like figures out how to stand up
or like she's saying like ball i'm like
i'm dead i'm like you're doing it on
your own i'm sorry i'm not like as
involved as i was with the others but
she's like she's so great and now she's
so interactive and i'm just like oh i'm
obsessed with you i had to work since
she was four months old so
um
i don't know just like
she's doing it herself and banks is
listening to your music now i can't
forget about bangs because that would be
a very middle child thing to do she's
listening to your music she's listening
to my music um
which means i have to listen to a lot of
my own music what's the song the song
right now is wake up
you